Three, two, one, go! He
had unknowingly wandered right up to
the front line. The first gunshot
signaled the beginning of another day's
Mayhem, an unforgettable ordeal with gangs. Over the next few days,
Kid r the city, so sold
of the
[Music]
variousb human
[Music] Hello,
I'm contacting you
today for a YouTube channel
called [Music]. I would like to ask a
few questions about your latest film
concerning chemical weapons. What is the name of the
film? It's called "
Chemical Weapons Under the Sea," and how long ago did you make it? We made it
last year. It was
broadcast on the Art channel in
February 2014. So this film deals with
global arsenals buried under the sea,
in lakes all over Europe.
What was the most polluted place
you were able to visit? Actually, it's
mainly the chemical weapons that were...
I was in the oceans, in the
seas, in all the oceans of the world, and
we filmed all over the world. TR
four  continents, and we can say that the
most polluted ocean or sea
was undoubtedly the Baltic. Polluted
with what? In the Baltic, it was
mainly mustard gas, which is called
in French "hit," I think it's called "hperit." So,
what is the risk, in fact, of this
burial under the sea?
What are the risks? The
risks are mainly for the fishermen, for
the fish, and for
the
marine environment. All the organizations
there, the researchers you were able to
meet who were investigating this
subject, gave you a deadline, a
critical time. The problem is that
most of these weapons were dumped
after the Second World War. There are
weapons that were dumped before that,
for the First World War, but
most were dumped after the Second
World War, and they were dumped
in... French barrels, those are
metal barrels,
and these barrels have a lifespan
of more or less
50 years due to corrosion. That is to say, we...  We are
now reaching a
pivotal moment, this is the
critical moment where these weapons are being deployed. The
barriers are being
opened and these chemical weapons are being deployed. Have
you investigated a
little bit about the English Channel, the
Mediterranean Sea, the French Riviera? Yes,
especially here in France,
on the French Riviera, there are areas where even
today we see signs where we ca
n't swim, but we don't know
why. It's because of chemical
weapons that have been dumped there. And
especially, we haven't filmed in France,
but we've filmed a lot in Italy, the
Adriatic coast, which is really another
coast that is very, very polluted. After the
Baltic, we can say that Italy
itself has a lot of chemical weapons
in the Adriatic Ocean. Have you
met with the population? Have you
discussed
the risk they face with the population?
Most of the
population isn't aware of this
problem because it's a sensitive subject.  It's very, very
secret, nobody's been talking about
it, and really, we can say that this
film is the first time it's been
discussed publicly. There have been
investigations done by
journalists, especially in Italy. One
journalist wrote a book about it, I don't know
how many years ago, but it was quite
recently, about five years ago. But it's
a new subject. And when
we talked to people we
were filming by the
sea, either on the Baltic Sea or
in Italy, and we met
people, they asked us what
we were doing, asked them if
they knew there were chemical weapons.
Everyone was very shocked. I think
the population isn't aware,
and it's a subject that frightens many people.
You were chosen to be the
director of this
documentary because you were
also the director of a film called "
Entraxoir."
Can you tell us a little about that film? Yes,
the film is...
A film that reflects the current state of
biological
research, the
ongoing development of biological agents,
and really, it's a film that started
after the Crax attacks, or just
after 9/11 in the United States.
Letters containing Crax's information were
sent to media outlets and
some American senators in
Washington. And you investigated
the strains of this DNA? Yes, we investigated. It was one of the
things
we did in this film: to
look at Crax's DNA to
find out where it came from and to conduct a
forensic investigation.
So, what
did you highlight about this strain?
If we look at this strain, it's what we
called a
weaponized strain, and it was very
sophisticated, developed with a
lot of resources. The conclusion, in
fact, was that it was
a strain that was really sophisticated, that it
must have come from a
state project.  It's impossible that a
person,
or even a small group of people,
could develop such a strain. These are very, very
powerful means. In your opinion, do
you think this was a
way for the state to intimidate
certain institutions to legitimize
some
anti-terrorism laws in the face of the spread
of biological weapons? We can't
know the reasons, in fact, but we ca
n't really speculate. But
it's certain that what
happened, that
these attacks,
launched a lot of new
research on biological weapons and a
lot of very, very large expenditures
and budgets that were allocated to
it. But we also know that
biological weapons aren't talked about
much, but that all states
are working on
it. You're a war reporter; you covered
some conflicts, like Moravia in the
Belle Époque. What
determined you, or what
predestined you, to investigate this type of
biological weapons scandal? For me, it came from growing up
in Africa, in Zimbabwe.
At the time, Zimbabwe was a British colony.  In
Rhodesia, we experienced a
very violent war of independence, and I grew up
in
Colon society. I was a young peasant, like any other peasant,
and when I reached adulthood,
the war was raging.
Many of my school friends went to fight, but I didn't. I ran away.
But later, after I became a
journalist, I learned that the Rwandan forces,
the government army,
used biological and chemical weapons,
and especially
anthrax.
Zimbabwe had the largest
anthrax epidemic in
1998, which killed over 300
people and infected over 10,000. And then, in
2001, I found myself in New York, right at
the time of the anthrax outbreak, and I wondered if there was
a connection.
Between what happened in my country
of Zimbabwe and what happened in the United States,
and that's what started the
film, it's about the consequences of this type of
reasoning. Yeah, it was a question,
it was interesting to see if there's
a link. Last
question for you, Bob, uh,
what is the worst conflict
you've had to witness during your
career as a
war reporter? All conflicts are bad,
terrible.
War is something awful to
experience, but we can say
perhaps Ivea was
particularly, we can say a bit crazy
because it was young men,
young people who were drugged with
drugs, a lot of confusion, a lot of
disorder, and a lot of danger.
Introduce us to your friend. So, I'll
introduce you to my partner, Eric Nadla. We
worked together on two
films:
Chemical Weapons Under the Sea and our film
Atrax War, which we also made together. And
that makes  10 years we work
enssazscentary 2
years what Drew me to this to is had
interest for many years in weapons of
mass destruction
whicht with the nuclear weapons
underground and we had exclusive access
to the first man accused of nuclear
espionage since Klaus fuk back in the
50s he was a German um he had access to
uranium enrichment technology um uh for
a firm where he worked and he took those
plans and he sold them to um Iraqi
agents for Saddam Hussein and there was
a worldwide Manhunt on for him after
those plans were found in a chicken
coop uh that the United Nations
inspectors were sent to by uh uh
Hussein's uh brother-in-law and uh as
soon as they saw the plans they knew
that this man carlheim SH had taken them
and he was hiding in Brazil and uhuse he
didn't think thered be an extradition
Treaty he also was helping Brazilians
with their secret nuclear program
helping them to Devel a nuclear
submarine among other things but
eventually the Brazilians  extradited
into Germany he stood trial he was
accused  of treason and nuclear espionage
he was found guilty and he was find
32,000 EUR and given a suspended
sentence he's a free man today and um
this was my first film on weapons of
mass destruction and then uh Bob and I
got together
bi we and weic we all ones and may
that's us now I don't know ok I would
point of view about the war in Iraq so
they talk about we of M
destruction arsenal of SAM was he and
legitimize the war this
pr point of
is at  some in the 190s he had a nuclear
program as many countries do
it and there was no real information
that he
had revived it again um he certainly had
the software the plans to that he obtain
from SH for uranium technology very very
very sophisticated stuff once he had
that who knows what he could do with it
could sell it whatever but the pretext
that he had biological weapons that he
had nuclear weapons um was uh never
proven so the basic justification uh for
that War I think was an illegitimate one
ultimately i think they cooked the books
the  Americans cooked the books skewed
the data linked  it to the media created
a frenzy and uh to this day they haven't
found any proof that his program
continued in a sophisticated manner uh
despite some moves back in the 90s in
fact
maradfi had a sophisticated program as
well he gave up the program um and uh
was one of the few countries to actually
give up program I don't know if that was
wise or not cuuse they eventually uh
ousted him and killed him um and so I
don't know what sign that sends to the M
and Iran what  you do with your weapons
but as far as the Iraq war goes i think
it was illegitimate and I think it was
done
some sort of revenge for 9 but nothing
to do with 9 so I think it's been a
tragedy for the region and the
world what was your your reaction when
you saw Colin po with a little bit of fr
who SH down tracks in front of a lot of
diplomatic persons well this is before I
did serious research into this topic
for the film this is when I was just an
American citizen and I was alarmed in
other words
if the American  intelligence people had
convinced Colin Pow  Who was kind of a
career soldier, not a real spooky guy, to
stand up in front of the world and say
that he was producing this? Well, I was
concerned, but as we know now, the
evidence wasn't there, and the speech he gave
was false. So, in retrospect,
I'm angry about that. But at the
time, I viewed it like most citizens and
was like that.
Bob, when you saw Colin Powell
waving a little anthrax, what was
your reaction at the time, and
what is your reaction now?
It was a very, very important point
for everyone who went into the war. Yes,
going into the war was
very important, and in our film, a
war, it's also a very important point
because,
through researching history, what happened
in the
biological fields? We were also concerned about the
deaths of researchers, several
researchers, and the most famous was
David Kelly, who was the one who
said, because when Colin Powell
took this anthrax, it was based on
intelligence they received from
the British, the Americans, and  In fact,
David Kelly spoke out against it and
said that the dossier had been fabricated, meaning
fabricated.
And it's because of this that the BBC had
a huge scandal because
he said
it
unofficially. But at the time, the BBC
gave his name; they said it was him who
had said it, and it caused a very, very
big scandal in England
that
almost forced Tron Holstein to resign
because of it. And it actually
caused David Kelly's death in one way or another.
It was said that he committed
suicide a few days after he
appeared before the British Parliament to
answer questions on the subject. It was a
very suspicious suicide in many
ways, but it was
undoubtedly a very, very
important moment for the
major powers to enter Iraq.
And as we know now,
9/11, Iraq—we are still living with the
consequences today.
I'm going to ask you both one last question.
then a penultimate
question sorry and then a last
question we are lucky to have
Americans in front of the camera I
would like to have your perception on the
concept of war against terrorism
terror it's hard to understand what
groups are out there who's doing who's
behind it who benefits from the chaos
that this war on terror causes um I know
a few things that have been done in the
name of the war on terror that uh
frighten me as a citizen uh basically in
terms of the United States the passing
of the Patriot Act civil  liberties are
threatened in fact in the recent
Revelations ofward Snowden we see that
national security state is an
international surveillance state gege
Orwell 1984 has come in the of the war
on terror
um it raises the question whether safety
or Liberty or
freedom can be Tred off in a way that
benefits many citizens so I think a lot
is done by the State in terms of the war
on terror that goes beyond things they've ever
done before and you go to the roots
of who's actually the terrorist out
there a few i don't  know
h people a handful of people are causing
these problems and  Uh, the films we're
doing lately look into these shadowy
wars. We're really not sure who the
players are, who they're working for, so
it raises a lot of questions. The war on
terror makes me uneasy because if
there are two terrors doing terrible
things, that's a horrible thing, but if
some governments are manipulating the
situation to increase their power, that's
also troubling. So I'm really
troubled by the entire scenario of the
post-9/11 world. Uh, I live in New York City. Uh,
I edited a film. Uh, downtown Manhattan, every night I looked out and I
saw the shining
R, the World Trade Center, and the
world that my children grew up in.
[Music]
Your perception of the war on
terror is, we can say it's a
war of... There are many things we don't
know,
and we have to ask ourselves, what does
terrorism mean? Also, I
grew up in Africa, and during the war of
liberation, we were told when I was growing up that it was
terrorists too.
And who are the real terrorists? What are...
It's about terrorism,
but we also have to look at the fact that
after the Cold War, we
needed—and still need—a
villain, an enemy,
someone to be afraid of, first of all to
control people. But above all, there's
the economic aspect:
immense spending, huge
budgets, the
militarization of the
armed forces under the name of the war on
terror. So there are many,
many questions we ask ourselves,
and we can really say that
since the war on
terror began after
9/11, the world has
completely changed. Last question: [
Music]
Question: Authority, as always, I tell you, don't believe what
you read in the
papers, don't believe what your government says. Think for yourself, and basically,
organize around issues that are important
to you. I think the hold of
power, at least in the United
States, I think basically the government
is run by a military-industrial complex
that supersedes Republicans or Democrats who have
come to believe that war is a
very profitable venture. We're living  In
a time of eternal war, and basically I
think you have to make the government
accountable for all its claims, so
basically question authority and don't
be afraid to engage in civil
disobedience when you don't believe
[Music].
It's really the same thing. I think
we should always not accept what we're told,
ask
questions, not trust what we're told, what we
read, what we
see on television. But I think
young people already know this. I
think this generation is already
aware of this and shouldn't be afraid to educate themselves, to
try to find
answers, to ask
questions, and above all, not be
afraid. We shouldn't be afraid; we must
have
courage. And it's really up to them to
change. We are our
generation; we have caused many
problems, but we will leave many
problems for the young people, and it's
really up to them, it's in their hands, to
change, to use the technology they have.  In a
smart way, because technology, the
internet, and all the information they
have at their fingertips can be
used negatively for
control, as we've seen, but it
can also
be used very, very
powerfully to change, to spread a wave of
good, an epidemic of good, thanks
to technology. That's exactly it.
Thank you very much, gentlemen. I
wish you a very good day.
[Music]
PL. From the moment we allow
operators to do what they want on
the network, we are in fact allowing them to
modify society, allowing them to
modify the way people
interact. Better and better, there are more and more
opportunities, more and
more knowledge and talent, more and more
solutions, and more and
more capital. That's for projects. What's currently
lacking is that
in many countries,
the institutional framework is evolving
to include civil society in the
debate, and we are very far from doing that in
France. I think it's even a bit of a
terror for institutions.